your goal throughout your wrestling
career
as you've beautifully put was to work so
hard that you pass out on the mat right
that you would be carried off the mat so
you never did successfully in
that's one of the ways you failed in
your careers you've never worked so hard
that you've passed out
have you ever come close do you remember
a time you've come close that you've
been pushed to the limits
of exhaustion you know the question is
really a good question about
that pushing to you collapse yeah
because
i don't as a coach today i don't think i
could if i said that to my athletes
i don't know i could get in trouble
because you know it's understood isn't
it by the athletes
yeah they understand it but the outside
might not understand it
because it's almost like what do you
mean they're you push them to the point
where they go
collapse that means they might die or
something might happen to them
and you know that's dangerous that's
dangerous we can't have our kid in that
type of atmosphere but it's something
that's
highly unlikely that's going to happen
but i'm going to tell you there's many
times in a practice
where i had pushed myself to all of a
sudden
the whistle blew or it was time to stop
and when i got up
off the mat or wherever i was at and i
needed water i need i needed fresh air
because you're usually in a fairly small
room with a lot of guys that the heat
rises and you know it's hard to breathe
and that i can remember and i stayed a
lot of times not by the door the far end
of the room
i can remember walking from the far end
of the room to that door
and i can remember am i going to make it
the next step
am i going to make it the next step i
need air i need water i need
oxygen i need to get out of here it
didn't happen often
but i can cut recount four or five times
in my career
that i pushed myself to that level where
i thought i was going to maybe
go out but every step i was dizzy
but once i got to that door i was able
to
open it and go out yeah and grab the
water and get cold water in my face and
so no i never really was able to do that
and i think the story is
in a book where my my daughter pushed a
collapse
molly he made you proud oh my gosh you
know she didn't win
yeah but she supposed to collapse yeah
now
did she suffer because of that
well she didn't get to go to the next
event because she didn't
she had to qualify but i think it
probably helped her too realizing
because she was wood in the race and she
was beating people she normally never
pushed
but she was at a new level that she had
never been before and she only needed
about
five feet to finish and it was just one
of those things that
i bet there was a lot of learning that
she did there and uh it probably
made her realize that she could be
better but she had to hold up though
you